two show references within the enemies
last night jimmy's a participation award
that he had there was a plaque and it
said jimmy
kimball kimball instead of kimmel and
also at the end of the broadcast
he said hey baba bowie stay safe
please vote and baba booth
you say baba bowie one of the greatest
no you know i'm worried about baba bowie
not gary because you know
golf is back but there's no
gallery is there what you're saying is
you're afraid
of it dying because there's no way to
shout out baba bowie yeah
but it's going nowhere howard you i
don't know if you heard but um
last night chuck schumer was giving a
press conference
somewhere outside of new york about ruth
bader ginsburg and how we should handle
everything
and the streets were empty and some guy
just came and screamed it out
what you're trying to tell robin and
others that there are if you use your
ingenuity
and you use your brain power there's a
place to yell out papa buy somewhere in
fact
the pga championship was held last month
that was in san francisco it's one of
the biggest tournaments of the year as
you know
no fans in attendance so how does this
happen
well here's a baba booey as uh daniel
berger teed off on the 12th hole safe to
say he hasn't hit a draw shot the entire
day
yeah this is not i'm not gonna like this
one
wow do you see how ingenious our
our fans are all right here's some other
baba buoys that have shown up all right
here's one a couple of months ago
spacex sent a rocket with two astronauts
aboard to the international space
station and back
discovery channel aired the splash down
of the rocket
the host was chris jacobs and he has
made several stern show references in
the past on other programs he kept the
street going when he said this at the
end of the broadcast
i'm sure we'll be hearing from them and
and you know
they're going to continue to hit them
with the high
hit him with a high we even got
mentioned in his soap opera on a recent
episode of days of our lives
my favorite the character named jake
lambert was drunk
and talking to a suit that belonged to
his dead twin brother when he said this
whoever said that the clothes make the
man
they're full of crap by bowie
say talking to his dead brother and he
said baba bowie
you